china is stepping up its military
activity around taiwan as tensions rise
following the u.s house speaker nancy
pelosi's visit
beijing is preparing its biggest show of
force around taiwan in decades the
government in taipei says it scrambled
jets to warn off chinese aircraft that
entered its air defense zone a number of
taiwanese ministry websites have come
under cyber attack pelosi left taiwan
pledging washington's ironclad
commitment to defending democracy there
a trip that has set the region on edge
the speaker of the u.s house of
representatives nancy pelosi arrives in
taiwan making her the highest level
american official to visit the island in
25 years
pelosi's stopover was kept deliberately
ambiguous amid stark warnings from china
and the threat of a military response
despite reservations in the biden
administration the white house insisted
that pelosi had a right to choose
whether to visit
and choose she did today our delegation
which i'm very proud
came to taiwan to make unequivocally
clear
we will not abandon our commitment to
taiwan and we are proud of our enduring
friendship today the world faces a
choice between democracy
and autocracy
america's determination to preserve
democracy here in taiwan and around the
world
remains ironclad
beijing's response was furious
what pelosi has done is by no means a
defense or protection of democracy but a
provocation in violation of china's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
china has vowed punishment
under the one china principle beijing
views the self-governing island as a
breakaway province and has not ruled out
reunification by force
it has announced a series of live-fire
military exercises surrounding the
island which taiwan warns will amount to
an air and sea blockade
but despite china's threats taiwan's
president xing-ven was resolute
facing deliberately heightened military
threats taiwan will not back down we
will firmly uphold our nation's
sovereignty and continue to hold the
line of defense for democracy
on the ground in the capital taipei
opinions were divided
some feared retaliation from china
after pelosi's visit taiwan is now
targeted i think she's making trouble
for us of course i am worried about
military confrontation
while others were less concerned
i'm used to china's threats i feel numb
i don't feel particularly nervous i
think that the media is exaggerating the
matter
with taiwan now effectively surrounded
by chinese military fears of a new
crisis in the taiwan strait are rising
all eyes are now on beijing
let's expand on this and bring ndw's
joyce lee who's in taipei
joyce give us the latest what's the
situation right now
so chinese navy ships and military
aircraft crossed the taiwan strait
median line several times today the
drill was initially planned for to last
for three days until sunday but the pla
announced today that they will extend
the drill for one more day
until monday and they added one more
zone for live fire drills so there's a
total of seven zones right now including
an area just 20 kilometers from the
southern city kaohsiung
china often holds military drills in the
taiwan straight but what we're seeing
now is something else entirely isn't it
why exactly are these latest exercises
so worrying
well the drill is unprecedented this is
the first time beijing tries to encircle
the island like this it's worth noting
that on china's social media weibo and
wechat chinese citizens have expressed
huge disappointment at
beijing's lack of action to stop pelosi
from visiting taiwan
many were expecting the pla to shoot her
plane down but it didn't happen of
course the public discontent is a huge
blow to xi jinping's authority
especially when he's under pressure to
look strong ahead of a party meeting
later this year many fear the pressure
could prompt
china to take even tougher measures
against taiwan and the drills could be
practicing for a future invasion
how big are fears of an escalation of an
invasion as you say
well um the de facto blockade means
isolation for taiwan so it's a direct
challenge to free air and sea navigation
and taiwanese fishermen rush to go back
to
the ports for their safety as for
international flights departing and
arriving in taiwan they have to fly
alternative routes to avoid the danger
zones so you can see
how dangerous it is now and taiwanese
officials say china's ambition is to
turn the taiwan strait into
non-international waters if china got
what it wanted it would undermine peace
and stability in the region
but i bet you've been talking to people
there in taipei are are people nervous
about this situation
maybe accidentally or willingly going
out of hand
well here in taipei city the mood is
generally calm for now because people
are just too used to china's threat
people are cautious but not too anxious
but in the southern region in taiwan
especially near the coast
people are quite nervous about their
safety
dw's joyce lee from taipei thank you
the association of southeast asian
nations is meeting in cambodia's capital
phnom penh china and the u.s are also
joining the summit the meeting has been
overshadowed by nancy pelosi's visit to
taiwan
asean chair cambodia has urged all sides
to de-escalate tension in the taiwan
strait the regional bloc warned on
thursday that there could be a quote
miscalculation and serious confrontation
richard heydarian is a political
scientist and has written extensively
about china's relations with southeast
asian nations and i asked him earlier
how much the tensions over taiwan would
actually overshadow this meeting
well it's element of geography right i
mean taiwan is actually perched at the
interstices of northeast asia and
southeast asia you know the philippines
the northern portions of the philippines
are separated from taiwan by just you
know a very narrow strait the luzon
strait there are a number of countries
in the region thailand philippines which
are u.s treaty allies some are partners
like singapore who could be dragged into
a conflict if something happens now both
taiwan and china have very robust
economic relationship with a lot of
countries in the region taiwan is a
global semiconductor superpower so what
happens there could affect also supply
chains around the region so i think
asean will do its best to come up with a
statement and at the same time on the
sidelines informally engage both china
u.s and other parties to ensure that the
situation will not get worse than it is
i think there's a lot of understanding
china has to put on some show to show to
uh you know to express this displeasure
but it has to be calibrated and not get
out of control because then we're going
to be in a very tough situation it's
loose loose for everyone
you have had an eye on china for quite
some time now now beijing launched what
may be the largest ever military
exercises encircling taiwan did you
expect this
oh yeah i mean uh the idea of xi jinping
not doing anything at all was completely
out of question right i mean he
repeatedly warned biden and the us not
to play with fire right and and china
doesn't want to look weak i mean xi
jinping is facing economic slowdown at
home he's expected to get a third term
in office later this year uh but those
are reasons for him to show something in
return i mean to show a level of
strength but at the same time i don't
think xi jinping is looking for a
massive conflict and if if there's a
precedence we have to look at is in 1995
1996 no
when we had the last time there was a
major conflict in the taiwan straits
during that period when china was
actually way weaker than the united
states compared to today and they had a
less nationalist leader like xi jinping
compared to today that time the the
chinese went as far as firing missiles
close to the shores of taiwan i don't
think we're there yet so yes the
situation is warring in the south china
sea warding around taiwan there are
fears of blockade further economic
sanctions but we have to keep things
into perspective we're still not even at
the level of the 1995-1996
taiwan straight crisis and we don't want
to even get there of course
we don't want to get there um you say
that xi jinping doesn't want to get
there but many observers believe that an
escalation either by choice or by
accident is only a matter of time so
would you share that assessment
yeah that is why it's extremely
important and this is in fairness by the
administration has also been doing that
they have super activated communication
channels on both military and civilian
level because i think there's an
anticipation that the probability
for accidental clashes or some major
incident is increasing by the day and
even if the nancy pelosi situation did
not create a world war iii i think this
is just an opening salvo in a very
perilous episode in u.s china relations
as far as taiwan is concerned and in the
meantime you can see even within taiwan
they're increasing divisions on these
visits and some people are asking
whether we wanted this kind of
expression of support by u.s because
they could still get a lot of support
without nancy pelosi visiting them and
provoking this kind of response from
china
interesting stuff richard hiderian thank
you so much
you